Great.
Now you've learned all about
monetization strategies and seen how
to submit any game to an App store.
>> We talked about how important it is
to start thinking about monetization
early on and went to with
the best design strategies for
finalizing your game.
>> Yeah, like how your game's appearance
in the App store can help it stand out
And how it's okay not to have
the perfect game before you launch it.
>> The important thing was to have
a strong game foundation, and
then make changes as you go along
based on the player feedback.
>> And you can get that feedback
directly from reviews or
from analyzing and
testing a game in real time.
Taking what you have learned in this
course, you now have a leg up on many
developers who leave monetization
strategies just as an after thought.
>> Congrats on finishing this course.
>> Time to get working on a new game.